hey 42 here WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange appeared on an episode of The
Simpsons he recorded his lines over the
phone from the Ecuadorian Embassy in
Britain where he has been granted asylum
welcome to
the use of the English word gay to mean
homosexual is older than the use of the
term homosexual to me gay
an octopus can use through an opening no
bigger than its own eyeball traffic in
central London moves it the same speed
as horse-drawn carriages did a century
ago people are 1% shorter in the evening
than they are in the morning the average
lifespan of a taste board is just 10
days one in five of the world
doctors are Russian beavers have
transparent eyelids so that they can see
underwater with their eyes short a group
of crows is called a murder as an Apple
falls to earth the earth falls very very
slightly towards the Apple the first
bomb the Allies dropped on Berlin in
World War 2 killed the only elephant
in Berlin Zoo every electron in the
universe knows about the state of every
other electron no matter how far apart
they are they are all connected by the
electromagnetic field which has an
infinite range ketchup was sold in the
1830s as medicine 12% of all coca-cola
in America is drunk at breakfast in 2012
22 baby girls in America were named
Kindle in an average year in Britain
trousers caused twice as many accidents
as chainsaws every time a woodpeckers
beak hits a tree its head is subject to
a thousand times the force of gravity
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2